airpot SPRO are now out and they're
honestly the best pair of wireless
earphones you can get in terms of the
overall package and how well they work
inside the Apple ecosystem but what if
you're an Android user well they still
work in sound great if you've got
something like the Galaxy Note 10.1
ality is a bit limited more on that in
just a minute
but let's first go through how to pair
the air pods Pro to your Android
smartphone as well as which features
work great for Android users first make
sure your airports pro are in the case
then go into the Bluetooth settings and
press and hold the button on the back of
the air pods case to enter pairing mode
keep holding the button and then tap on
the air pods Pro when they show up in
the available devices menu and you're
done one of the best things about ear
pods Pro regardless of which phone you
use it with is the fit feel and comfort
they fit great because they come with
three different sizes of supersoft
silicone ear tips and the best part is
that the speaker grille itself is
actually flush with the pod so only the
soft ear tips go into your ears unlike
basically all other inner ear phones
that have a hard plastic tube that goes
into your ear canal but it doesn't stop
there the air boss pro have a venting
feature that automatically equalizes the
pressure inside of your ears to match
the outside world so your ears will
never feel plugged which is the worst
thing about earphones that seal these
two things make the air pods Pro the
most comfortable in ear earphone since
basically ever and it's the best reason
you should actually buy them if you're
an Android user most Android users will
probably love the new short stem design
compared to the old ear pods so the look
and feel great
and yes the noise cancellation features
work perfectly well on Android devices
just like they do with iPhones and same
with all the force sensing controls
including pausing and playing skipping
tracks and cycling between noise
cancellation and transparency modes
these controls work flawlessly on the
note 10 plus noise cancellation is
seriously amazing and it works well
enough to make this feature alone worth
upgrading from air pods to but the
transparency mode is actually the most
impressive part and it works great with
Android phones as well it basically uses
a microphone to record your surroundings
and then
speakers play it directly into your ears
so instead of everything sounded muted
like you have earplugs in it sounds like
you have literally nothing blocking your
ears and one thing that people love
about ear pods is the excellent
microphone quality during calls and yes
it's great on Android phones as well
it's also pretty awesome that Apple
included a lightning to USB C cable in
the box and since most Android phones
come with USB C chargers you're pretty
much set and of course the air pods pro
case also supports qi wireless charging
so you can avoid using the lightning
cable altogether the case is also pretty
small and more portable than a lot of
other earphones which is one of my
favorite things about airports now
getting into sound quality B sound
absolutely amazing the best way to
explain it is that the air Potts pro are
more than loud enough while producing
some of the most accurate sound quality
out there there are some competing ear
phones like the galaxy buds echo buds
and power beats Pro that produced louder
bass but the air paws Pro beat all of
them hands-down and overall sound
quality in accuracy the air pod pros are
also the best overall package out of all
of these earphones combining everything
from ipx4 water resistance active noise
cancellation incredible comfort great
battery life
awesome portability and more well each
of those other options lack at least one
or two things that the air pause pro
have now let's go through the features
that you miss out on if you use air pods
pro on an android smartphone the hey
Siri feature obviously won't work to
activate Google assistant so you'll have
to use your phone which honestly isn't a
big deal on iOS you can customize
controls so you can press and hold to
access Siri on one side and use noise
controls on the other on Android both
sides will default to cycling between
noise controls which in my opinion is
perfectly fine for most people of course
you also don't have access to the Apple
ecosystem which instantly sets up air
pods on the rest of your Apple devices
that are logged into the same iCloud
account for Android users that doesn't
even matter at all on iPhone it's very
simple to check your battery life by
simply opening up the case next to your
iPhone now that actually are some apps
you can download on Android to check
battery life but they don't work nearly
as well as apples in
limitation and finally there's automatic
ear detection on iOS which automatically
pauses your music when you take an air
pot out of your ear and plays it again
when you put it back in this is a pretty
great feature that unfortunately doesn't
work on Android but now that you can
easily pause music with a single press
on the stem it's actually quicker than
taking your air pod out of your ear and
even better the new transparency mode
makes it so that you can hear your
surroundings and actually have a
conversation with someone while wearing
the air pods Pro as long as your volume
isn't set too high and a major plus is
that you can take one ear pod out of
your ear and put it into the case to
charge and your music will continue to
play in the other ear and when you take
the airport back out of the case and put
it into your ear it'll automatically
play a couple of seconds later which is
honestly one of my favorite ear pod
features so in my opinion the ear pods
on Android experience has never been as
good as it is on the air pods Pro the
many positives easily outweigh the
smallest of negatives so in reality I
would greatly recommend the air pods Pro
to everyone including Android users if
this video helped you out you can use
the link below to order some air paws
Perl right now from Amazon and help
support the channel and if you enjoyed
it go ahead and tap that like button
right there and click the circle about
to subscribe for more videos like this
one and be sure to check out our full
air Prospero review right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]